one of the most important things for a
pilot to know how to do is to keep from
running into other aircraft and in order
to do that you need to know the Federal
Aviation regulations that deal with that
today on free pilot training I'm going
to go into the collision avoidance
regulations and you need to know this
for your check ride but these are also
going to keep you safe when you go out
and fly
probably one of the most important
things to keep you from hitting other
aircraft is to know who has the right of
way when you meet another pilot and
while we all laugh at this meme there's
also a little bit of Truth in it because
things can get scary pretty quickly if
you get too close to another aircraft
now you may remember getting your
driver's license and learning who has
the right-of-way when you come to a stop
sign and if you don't remember that was
probably me honking at you last week to
let you know that it was your turn to go
anyway we learned these things when
we're learning how to drive so we know
whose turn it is but you can't just stop
in midair in an airplane so it's even
more important for us to learn who has a
right-of-way as a pilot because it
allows us to predict what the other
aircraft is going to do so we don't have
a mid-air Collision
now as you may remember from the last
lesson part 91 is where we find the
general operating and flight rules so
you'll find a lot of what we're talking
about here and when it comes to safely
operating your other aircraft a good
starting point for that is far 91 111.
this is where you'll find some of the
general rules for operating near other
aircraft now as you can see here no
person may operate an aircraft so close
to another aircraft as to create a
collision Hazard so not only is it
dangerous to get super close to another
aircraft it's also illegal as well now
there is one exception to this Rule and
that's if you're flying formation and
formation flying is some of the coolest
flying you'll ever do but here in Far
9111 there are a couple additional rules
you need to fall if you want to do that
first you cannot operate an aircraft in
formation flight except by prior
arrangement with the pilot in command of
each aircraft in the formation
and if you are formation flying you
cannot carry passengers For Hire when
you do that okay now that you know that
let's get get on to talking about those
right-of-way rules you'll find these in
Far 9113 so if you're tabbing out your
far aim this is a good one to Tab out
first I want to point out that it
doesn't matter whether you're flying
under IFR or VFR every person operating
an aircraft needs to be constantly
Vigilant so as to see and avoid hitting
other aircraft and just because you have
the right of way that doesn't mean you
can just keep on doing what you're doing
maybe you have the right of way over Joe
Bob and his Piper Cub but if he doesn't
ever see you he may just run right into
you because he doesn't know you're there
and at that point it doesn't matter who
had the right of way you're both dead
and it's a moot point
all right so first things first aircraft
in distress have the right of way over
all other air traffic and they use the
word air traffic on purpose here because
it doesn't matter what category of
aircraft you're flying if you're in
distress you have the right of way over
everyone else now here's something
important to keep in mind how is anyone
going to know that you're in distress if
you don't tell anyone that's why it's
super important to declare an emergency
if you really are in distress especially
if you're having problems controlling
the aircraft or you lost your engine or
something yes it's important to aviate
navigate and then communicate but you're
not going to get priority if you don't
tell ATC that you're actually having an
emergency now if you simply can't get
the radio call out because you have a
handful of airplane it's totally fine to
explain to the FAA that you were in
distress after the fact but if you have
the time get that radio call out there
it could make the difference in your
situation okay but what if two aircraft
meet and neither one of them is in
distress now what well who has the right
of way depends on the category of
aircraft that you're flying and as a
general rule if an aircraft is less
maneuverable it has the right of way
for example a balloon has a right-of-way
over any other category of aircraft
because it's a lot harder for these guys
to steer and keep themselves from
hitting other aircraft
next we have the glider now these guys
can steer a little easier than the
balloon but they're limited on where
they can steer because if they want to
stay airborne they need to stay in areas
where there's more lift because they
don't have an engine
after that an aircraft towing or
refueling another aircraft has a
right-of-way over all other engine
driven aircraft and this includes an
Airship which is the next aircraft on
our right-of-way list this would be like
the Goodyear blimp you sometimes see
flying over football games these are a
little bit more maneuverable than the
first couple aircraft that we discuss
but they're still very slow and can't
move as quickly as most other aircraft
as you can see here we clearly have four
categories of aircraft left
this rag makes no mention of who has a
right-of-way over the other ones and I
personally think that's a foul because
you have to go digging in the ultra
light rig Which is far 103 to see that
ultralight aircraft are required to give
way to all other aircraft
so next we have airplanes and
helicopters and as far as right-of-way
is concerned helicopters and airplanes
are considered equal because they're
roughly the same when it comes to
maneuverability but these powered
parachutes and weight shift aircraft
with engines are the lowest on the totem
pole and they must avoid everyone else
alright now that we know that let's take
a look at some of the situations you
could get into with other aircraft what
happens if 2 aircraft are converging at
roughly the same altitude who needs to
give way well if the aircraft are
converging head-on the aircraft category
does not matter both aircraft should
avoid hitting the other aircraft by
altering their course to the right
that's pretty simple to remember unless
you're British you shouldn't have lost a
war you could have made us Ultra course
to the left instead but since you didn't
we make right turns to avoid hitting
other aircraft if we're approaching
head-on anyway what if we're converging
with another aircraft and we're not
approaching head-on well first it
depends on the category of aircraft if
I'm flying my Cessna 172 which is an
airplane and I'm converging with the
Goodyear blimp he has a right-of-way so
I need to avoid hitting him and the way
I do that is to pass behind him if I can
that's not always going to be possible
climbing might be a better option in
some cases but passing behind is
typically the preferred method but what
happens if I'm flying an airplane and I
meet someone else flying an airplane who
has it right away the right-of-way rule
in this case is just like the one you
learned when you're getting your
driver's license whoever is on the right
has the right of way
so if this airplane right here is me
this airplane is on my right so he has
it right away
he needs to just maintain a predictable
flight path and I will alter my course
to avoid hitting him
now as we mentioned a second ago if I
don't ever see him that doesn't
alleviate his responsibility for
avoiding a dangerous situation he may
need to climb or something to keep us
from hitting each other but he does have
the right of way because he is on the
right okay what if I'm overtaking or
passing a slower aircraft who has it
right away
once again the category of aircraft does
not matter and the aircraft being
overtaken has the right of way
now if you're passing another aircraft
you should always pass him on the right
side this one might seem a little bit
more natural for my British friends but
the reason for this is because the pilot
in command typically sits in the left
seat and it's a little bit easier to
make sure that you have plenty of
clearance when you pass the other
aircraft but even if you are flying from
the right seat for some reason you
should still overtake another aircraft
on the right side this is going to make
you a lot more predictable to the other
pilot and it's going to make the
situation a lot safer now this raises an
important question how do I know if the
airplane I'm meeting or converging with
is headed right towards me headed away
from me or simply converging from the
left or to the right during the day this
can be extremely difficult but the best
way to know for sure is to look for
relative movement if the aircraft seems
to be moving at all it's most likely
moving to the left or to the right
you're simply converging if the aircraft
appears to be stationary you're either
catching up to them from behind or
you're converging head-on and this is
another reason why we over take another
aircraft on the right because it can be
really difficult to tell whether you're
converging head-on or you're overtaking
them until you're right on the other
aircraft and altering your course to the
right keeps you from getting beat to
beak with that other aircraft
now at night we have lights that help us
tell which direction the other aircraft
is going but before we talk about how to
know which direction they're going I
want to discuss aircraft lighting for a
minute because like questions are some
of the most asked questions on the check
ride
all the lights on your airplane are
there to help other aircraft see you so
they can avoid hitting you but which
ones are required and when are they
required you'll find most of the
lighting requirements in far 91205 and
Far 91209 91 205 is the reg where we get
our famous a tomato Flames required
equipment list and this is probably the
most important rig to tap out in your
far aim if you do that there are a lot
of important things to know in here but
as far as lighting is concerned there
are basically four different types of
Lighting systems you should be familiar
with first and probably the most
important is what we call the
anti-collision lighting system this
lighting system can come in a few
different styles depending on when the
aircraft was made but typically you'll
find one light on the tail and or one
light on the belly of the aircraft and
these can be a rotating Beacon or a
strobe light that flashes and they're
usually red or white and as you might
have guessed these lights flash so they
can catch the attention of other Pilots
typically on older aircraft you'll find
that they have a rotating Beacon and the
newer ones they'll often have a beacon
and a strobe which is way easier to see
but it's also super distracting
now according to far 91209 anytime we're
operating an aircraft that has an
anti-collision light we have to have
this thing turned on I take that to
Maine anytime from the time I start up
the engine until the time that I shut
down the engine
if I'm getting towed with the engine
shut down I would probably turn it on
for that as well but there are actually
some older aircraft that were built
without an anti-collision light and if
you're flying one of these you don't
have to have it turned on because you
don't have one but if it's got one you
have to use it now with that in mind
according to far91 209 the
anti-collision lights need not be
lighted when the pilot in command
determines that because of operating
conditions it would be in the interest
of safety to turn the lights off
now every CFI has his own take on this
but my personal opinion is that when I
start the engine I turn on the beacon
and the strobe if the airplane has it
and I operate that way until I feel like
it's unsafe
you may be asking why would it be unsafe
to operate with the anti-collision light
on I've never personally felt like I
needed to turn the beacon off for any
reason but the strobe lights and some of
the newer anti-collision light systems
can be extremely distracting especially
if you're operating under IFR in Cloudy
conditions the strobe will reflect off
those clouds and it can cause you to get
spatially disoriented the strobes can
also be pretty distracting to other
pilots who are landing if you're holding
short at the approach in and waiting for
your turn to take off and because of
that a lot of instructors will teach
students to only use the strobes when
they take the runway
either way the anti-collision light is
the most important one for you to
remember because it's the one that you
need to have on all the time
but what about that Landing light do we
need a landing light well in 91 205 in
addition to our VFR day equipment
requirements we also have things that we
have to have with us at night as well to
remember the nighttime stuff I like to
use acronym flaps
and as you can see the landing light is
on this list but if you read the actual
reg it says that if the aircraft is
operated for Higher One electric Landing
light so if you're not operating for
hire you technically don't need a
landing light but I want to ask you a
question do you really want to land an
aircraft at night without a landing
light now you may not even know the
answer to that question but I would
encourage you to try a landing or two
with your instructor with the landing
lights off during your training this
will help you decide whether or not you
want to fly an aircraft after dark that
has a burned out Landing light it'll
also give you a taste of what to expect
if your Landing light burns out on you
for some reason now what about the taxi
lights when are those required
oddly enough taxi lights are never
required but they're nice to have and if
your Landing light is burned out but you
have taxi lights and you're not
operating for hire you can use your taxi
lights to help you see when you're
Landing you don't just have to have them
for taxing even though they make it a
lot easier for that as well last but not
least we need to have approved position
lights if we're going to be flying at
night
and over in 91 209 it specifically says
that from Sunset to Sunrise we need to
turn those on if you're flying in Alaska
for some reason there are a few
additional times when you need to turn
those on but everywhere else you need to
flip those puppies on right at Sunset
then leave them on until the sun comes
back up sometimes the switch in your
airplane might label these as navigation
lights or nav lights this is the same
thing as position lights
now there are three physical lights in
the position lighting system that need
to be working and on in order to operate
legally after sunset
there's a red bulb on the left wing tip
a green bulb on the right wing tip and a
white bulb at the tip of the tail
now on most aircraft you can only see
the red and green bulbs from the front
of the aircraft or the side of the
aircraft but these lights are not
visible if you're looking at the
aircraft from the rear and there's a
really good reason for that let's say
you're flying along and you see a green
and a red light like this which way is
this guy facing and since we're on the
subject who has the right of way
well a good memory aid is green and red
you're dead and while you won't be able
to see the white light on the tip of the
tail the other guy could have his
Landing light on and sometimes those are
right in the middle of the aircraft so
if you see that don't let that throw you
off now here's how I remember the red
and green light and you guys let me know
what you think about this method the
whole purpose in these position lights
is so you can determine who has the
right-of-way
what better way to do that than to put a
stop light on each aircraft
if I see a red light I'll see the white
tail as well and I should also see a
beacon but the red light I'm seeing on
the wingtip tells me to stop because
this guy is on my right and he has it
right away if I see a green light I
should also see the white tail light in
the beacon as well but the green light
is telling me to go because I'm on his
right and that means I have the right
away
and if for some reason I only see a
small white light there should also be a
beacon right here somewhere as well but
if I'm not saying the red and green I'm
most likely seeing the rear end of this
aircraft and if I'm overtaking him I
need to move to his right like we talked
about before all right before we move on
to another subject there's one more
thing you should know about the
navigation or position lights if your
instructor has been having you operate
with the nav lights turned on all the
time there's a good chance that you have
one of these things right here in the
place of one of the three normal
position lights if that's the case this
weird thing is your adsb out and you
need to leave that on all the time and
in order to do that with this particular
system you have to leave your nav lights
turned on and you want to do that
because if you have adsb installed on
your aircraft you're required to always
keep that on no matter what type of air
space you're operating in I've talked
about adsb quite a bit in other episodes
so let's look at a couple more things
you should know about right away
what if we're coming in for a landing
and someone is holding short of the
runway who has the right of way
well according to 9113 aircraft that are
landing had the right-of-way over all
other aircraft on the surface but you
cannot take advantage of this rule to
force an aircraft Off The Runway surface
which has already landed and is
attempting to make way for an aircraft
on Final Approach that's why it's so
important to check Final before you take
the runway especially at a non-towered
Airfield not only do we want to stay
alive but that guy Landing also has the
right-of-way over us but what if two
aircraft are both in the air and both
are approaching to land who has right
away then
in this situation the aircraft at the
lower altitude has the right-of-way but
it shall not take advantage of this rule
to cut in front of another which is on
Final Approach to land or to overtake
that aircraft now if you're learning to
operate a seaplane there are a few
additional right-of-way rules for those
in 91-115 but the big thing to know
about seaplane operations is that
seaplanes need to stay as far away from
other vessels on the water as possible
if for some reason a seaplane and a
motorboat or other vessel meet each
other on the water technically they
should follow similar rules as airplanes
in the air in a head-on situation both
should alter their course to the right
if a boat in a seaplane are crossing
each other the plane or vessel on the
right has the right way the person on
the left should pass behind the other
if you're overtaking a vessel or they're
overtaking you for some crazy reason the
person being overtaken has the right of
way
the reg doesn't specifically say to pass
on the right but I could see why that
might not always be the best choice if
there's something you might run into
over there
now take all this with a grain of salt
because I bet that most people out there
driving boats have no clue what the
right-of-way rules are when they meet a
seaplane you may have to be the one that
does all the work to avoid a collision
now that we understand right away let's
take a look at a few more things that
can help keep us from running into other
Pilots now you may not believe this
since the training aircraft are flying
is relatively slow but there are
actually speed limits in the air that
you need to be aware of as a Private
Pilot
if you ever get your high performance
endorsement you could potentially break
the law if you fly too fast in certain
airspace these speed limits are posted
in Far 91 117.
so first things first at 10 000 feet MSL
and above you can literally fly as fast
as you want as long as you don't break
the sound barrier now breaking the sound
barrier can be a complicated topic but
at sea level on a standard day that's
about 661 knots
this is what we refer to as Mach 1 but
you really don't need to know that for
today's lesson because if you break the
sound barrier in your Cessna you will
definitely break the Wings off before
you crash right into the ground just
know that there really isn't a speed
limit at 10 000 feet and above that you
need to worry about below 10 000 feet
MSL is another story though
anytime we're below 10 000 feet in the
U.S you cannot exceed 250 knots
indicated air speed
now indicated air speed is very
important here because that's what
you're going to see on your airspeed
indicator so you don't have to worry
about true AirSpeed ground speed or
anything else just worry about what you
see in front of you
the next speed limit you need to know
about is anytime you're flying within
four miles of the primary airport in
class Delta or Charlie airspace if
you're flying at or below 2500 AGL
in this case you cannot fly faster than
200 knots indicated now what if I'm four
miles from this class Charlie airspace
right here and I'm at 2300 feet AGL
what's my speed limit well we still need
to be under 250 knots indicated but the
reg says within four nautical miles of
the primary airport so we technically
don't need to slow below 200 knots
indicated but as we get closer to the
airport we need to make sure our
airspeed indicator is showing below 200
knots and don't forget this also applies
when we're within four miles of the
primary airport in class Delta as well
so if you're getting close to one of
those two types of airspace be sure to
keep that in mind last but not least we
have class Bravo airspace and oddly
enough class Bravo does not have a speed
limit when you're actually inside the
airspace however if you're below 10 000
feet you still can't fly over 250 like
we mentioned a second ago and actually
if you're at 10 000 feet MSL and above
you can actually fly as fast as you want
through Bravo as long as you're not
breaking the sound barrier if you ever
find the Denver area their class Bravo
goes all the way up to 12 000 feet MSL
so there's actually a 2 000 foot sliver
of airspace where you can fly as fast as
you want and I know this seems kind of
backwards since the whole point in these
speed limits is to keep everyone from
running into each other at higher speeds
but class Bravo airspace is very heavily
controlled and those ATC guys have the
best radar systems out there so high air
speeds aren't really an issue for those
guys with that in mind sometimes it may
want you to slow down so you don't mess
up the sequencing or spacing they have
to get everyone to the runway if this
happens they may issue you a speed
restriction like this
32424 Victor maintain 200 knots or
slower until established on a five mile
final 200 knots or slower until five
mile final Mooney 2424 Victor at this
point we do have a speed limit and now
we need to follow it now while there's
no speed limit inside of class Bravo
there is a speed limit you need to be
aware of if you're going to be flying
below the class Bravo Shelf
if you're flying down here you need to
keep your AirSpeed below 200 knots
indicated
and if you fly through a VFR Corridor
which goes through the class Bravo
airspace this 200 knot speed limit
applies to you as well
technically you're not in class Bravo if
you're in one of these corridors and
because of that you need to keep your
AirSpeed below 200 knots now that you
know your speed limits let's take a look
at another important regulation in Far
91 121 did you know that you're required
to keep your altimeter updated
throughout your flight now you may have
thought that the altimeter is only there
to keep you from running into towers and
other stuff like that but actually it
can help you from running into other
aircraft as well
take a look at what the regulations say
over in Far 91 121
each person operating an aircraft shall
maintain the cruising altitude or flight
level of that aircraft as the case may
be by reference to an altimeter that is
set okay so this thing says that we must
maintain a specific cruising altitude
first of all how are we going to be able
to do that without an altimeter well you
can't and it's no wonder why far 91205
lists the altimeter as a required piece
of equipment
you need to maintain a certain cruising
altitude and we also see here that our
altimeter needs to be properly set if
you're going to be flying below 18 000
feet MSL you need to use a current
altimeter setting along the route of
flight within 100 nautical miles of the
aircraft
well how do we get these current
altimeter settings if you're on flight
following with ATC or if you're on an
IFR clearance ATC should be giving you
periodic updates of the current
altimeter setting in your area
two niner eight Niner 220-29 or eight
nine or Mooney 2424 Victor now that he
hooked me up with the current altimeter
setting I can just spin that into my
kohl'sman window and I know this thing's
going to give me good data I can also
just tune the nearest awos Asos or Aegis
frequency along my route of flight let's
tune in this frequency right here and
see what the current altimeter setting
is
Zulu wind missing visibility one zero
Sky condition scattered 5 500.
temperature 1-3 Celsius dew point zero
eight Celsius altimeter two niner eight
four remarks density altitude 400 sounds
like we need to spin in two nine or
eight four into our altimeter two easy
now there may be times when there's not
a station within 100 miles of your
aircraft along your route of flight in
that case this line basically says to
pick the closest appropriate station
available
it's better to use an altimeter that's
somewhat accurate than to be completely
off
with that in mind if for some reason you
don't have a radio there's not a lot you
can do from the air except to use
products like forefly or Garmin pilot on
your tablet or phone but the preferred
method is to find the filled elevation
at your takeoff location and to spend
that into your altimeter and this is
going to give you a fairly accurate
reading as long as you're flying in that
local area
once you get your instrument rating you
can start flying in class Alpha airspace
which starts at 18 000 feet in a Cell at
an above 18 000 feet everyone up there
is flying on an IFR clearance and when
you're flying up there you're required
to set your altimeter at two nine or
nine or two so at an above 18 000 feet
MSL everyone up there is actually flying
specific pressure altitudes because if
you remember when we set our altimeter
at 299 or two this thing actually gives
us our height above the standard datum
plane now as I mentioned a minute ago
there are basically two reasons why we
want to have the most up-to-date
altimeter setting first and foremost we
want to make sure that you're not
getting too bored when you're out flying
around Pilots should be as busy as
possible no I'm just kidding about that
there's a good reason for this rig first
we don't want to run into any terrain or
obstacles if we know the elevation of a
tower or a mountain or something it
makes it a lot easier to know for sure
that we're not going to run into this
thing especially if we're flying in the
clouds the other reason is so that we
don't run into other Pilots I want you
to take a look at these two aircraft
that are flying directly at each other
this aircraft is flying at an indicated
altitude of 4500 feet MSL and this
aircraft is flying at an indicated
altitude of 5000 feet MSL let's say the
current altimeter setting was 3012 these
guys didn't think it was a big deal so
they didn't change their altimeters from
what they had at their departure
location
they may have thought they were here but
in reality they're at the same altitude
headed right for each other now I know
that there are a lot of tools out there
that can help keep you from running into
other aircraft and ATC can help too but
ultimately it's your responsibility as
the pilot in command to see and avoid
hitting other aircraft and part of being
able to do that is one setting the
proper altimeter setting and two flying
the correct cruising altitude doing
these two things will ensure you have
plenty of separation between you and the
other aircraft around you now if you're
wondering what the proper cruising
altitude is you can find the answer to
that in Far 91 159 if you're flying
within three thousand feet of the
surface or 3000 AGL and Below you can
basically fly whatever altitude you feel
like is safest now obviously you still
need to use the appropriate pattern
altitudes and stuff like that but as a
general rule below 3000 AGL you can fly
the altitude you need to and this allows
you to fly under class Charlie's Shelfs
and other stuff like that but if you fly
above 3000 AGL and you're operating
under VFR then you need to fly the
appropriate cruising altitude now that
cruising altitude you fly is based on
the magnetic course you're going to be
flying it's not actually based on your
heading as long as your GPS is
displaying data in reference to magnetic
north and not true north your magnetic
course would just be the track you see
right here on the GPS okay so what if
we're flying VFR on a magnetic course of
0 to 179 that's when we want to make
sure that we're flying our odd altitudes
plus 500 feet
then if we're following VFR on a MAG
course of 180 all the way up to 359 then
we need to fly even altitudes plus 500.
if you're looking for a memory aid neod
and Sweden are two of the best ones out
there if we start at North which is
exactly zero or 360 degrees and we move
around the east side of the compass when
we're on any one of these courses here
we need to be using odd altitudes plus
500 if we're flying VFR once you get
your instrument rating you'll actually
be flying at the odd altitude without
that 500 foot Edition this gives us
plenty of separation between all
aircraft VFR and IFR that are flying in
the opposite direction if we start on
South which is exactly 180 degrees and
we move around the west side of the
compass all the way to 359 we'll use
Sweden which means that if we're on a
MAG course of 270 and we're flying VFR
we need to choose an even altitude plus
500 feet if I'm flying IFR I need to
choose an even altitude without the 500
foot Edition and as you can see even if
we meet in IFR aircraft traveling in the
opposite direction as long as we both
have the proper altimeter set we should
not run into each other
now I do want to mention that when
you're making a turn you don't have to
change your altitude during the turn to
stay legal 91 159 clearly states that
you can just keep your altitude through
the turn
once you're done with the turn if you
need to climb or descend to get the
proper cruising altitude go ahead and do
that after you're done making the turn
you'd be amazed at how many times I've
been asked that question anyway the
whole point in this regulation is so we
can be predictable so we can avoid
collisions
how predictable do you think it's going
to be if you're turning and you start to
climb or descend just because you're
making a turn through one of these
magnetic courses well if I'm over here I
won't know if you're climbing or
descending until I see the whites of
your eyes what's another way we can be
predictable I know every CFI here is
saying talk about traffic patterns and I
want to do that but there's way too much
information to talk about in today's
lesson but when it comes to collision
avoidance there's a few things you
should know about first check out this
brief little note from 91130 no person
may take off or land an aircraft at a
satellite airport within a Class C
airspace area accepting compliance with
FAA arrival and departure traffic
patterns think about it in class Charlie
approaches vectoring a lot of aircraft
into the airspace and it's their
responsibility to keep aircraft
separated and it's virtually impossible
for them to do that if you're not flying
a predictable pattern there's actually
some really good information on how they
do that in the aim in paragraph 3-2-4
the part where it talks about aircraft
separation is really interesting because
because how much spacing they make for
you depends on a few different factors
okay so what are some ways we can be
predictable in the pattern this isn't
really a problem at a towered Airfield
because we just need to do what we're
told but if we want to be predictable at
class golf at a non-towered Airfield one
way we can do that is to make left turns
like it tells us to do in 91 126. of
course there are lots of runways out
there that have right patterns instead
and we could easily find that
information on the VFR sectional like
you see here
the charge supplement is a good place to
get that information too but a lot of
times they'll even be visual markings on
the airport to let us know which way we
need to make our turns now there are a
handful of airports out there that has
special rules and procedures you'll find
a majority of these up in Alaska and
their charge supplement has a lot of
good information so if you're going to
be flying up there you really need to
take a good look at their chart
supplement if you want to be predictable
part 93 has a few additional things for
the super busy airports across the
country as well but a good place to
start for every place you go fly is the
chart supplement so being predictable
and flying the proper cruising altitude
are two things you can do to keep from
crashing into other aircraft but another
thing you can do is to do what ATC tells
you to do let's take a look at far 91123
as you can see this reg deals with
clearances and instructions and when it
comes to these there's a couple things
in here you really need to be aware of
first when an ATC clearance has been
obtained no pilot in command May deviate
from that clearance unless an amended
clearance is obtained an emergency
exists or the deviation is in response
to a traffic alert and collision
avoidance system resolution advisory now
I'll explain what this traffic alert and
resolution advisory thing is here in a
minute but notice here that when it
comes to a clearance if you're ever
uncertain you need to immediately
request clarification ATC controllers
use standard terminology to make sure
you know exactly what they're talking
about but they can sometimes make
mistakes too and use not non-standard
terminology that might be confusing and
this brings up an important question
what happens when a pilot makes a
mistake well the pilot dies but what
happens when ATC makes a mistake that's
right the pilot still dies and while we
all chuckle at my dark sense of humor
there's quite a bit of Truth in that so
you should always clarify if there's a
question about a clearance ATC has given
you now notice here that accepting an
emergency no person may operate an
aircraft contrary to an ATC instruction
in an area in which air traffic control
is exercised and this brings up an
important conversation first of all you
can see here that we have two different
things we can get from ATC clearances
and instructions clearances give you
authorization to do certain things when
you're at a towered Airfield you have to
be cleared to land or cleared for
takeoff if you want to go into class
Bravo airspace you need to be cleared
into the class Bravo and these
clearances need to be followed no matter
what airspace you're in and you also
need to read those clearances back as
closely as possible to the control
roller so there's no uncertainty
whatsoever
but with that in mind there's something
important you need to keep in mind about
clearances
when ATC gives you a clearance that's
basically clearance to proceed it does
not alleviate your responsibility of not
running into other people and it also
doesn't necessarily give you priority
over other aircraft as you continue to
fly one of the most common examples of
this is when two aircraft get cleared to
land at the same time
[Music]
7348 Juliet
t-7348 Juliet number two clandoland
three six number two clear the land
three six Cherokee 7348 Juliet now
notice the tower told us that there's a
Cessna 172 on a one mile final once we
told him that we had the traffic in
sight he told us that we were number two
and he cleared us to land but the Cessna
has priority over us because he's number
one just because you have a clearance
that doesn't give you priority over
other aircraft in addition to that a
clearance doesn't necessarily give you
separation from other aircraft yes ATC
sometimes provides separation from other
aircraft for you in certain airspace but
once you have that other aircraft in
sight ATC doesn't actually have to
provide any separation in some cases
that's your responsibility even before
you see that other traffic to make sure
you're not going to hit someone else
that's why you should always be scanning
the area even if you are in controlled
airspace
now there are some clearances that you
won't always hear the words cleared to
do this or clear to do that
taxi clearances are a good example of
this after you land as you probably
already know you need a taxi clear the
runway and that means taxing past the
VFR hold line and in case you didn't
know you should not automatically switch
to ground after landing at a fill with
control tower sometimes the tower will
control taxi clearances that cross a
Runway but if they want you to switch
you'll often hear a radio call like this
[Applause]
Juliet now as I've said before it's not
uncommon to get the famous ground Point
Niner or ground point seven or whatever
a majority of the ground frequencies are
one two one point something so if you
get this just know that ground is on one
two one point nine they're just trying
to sound as cool as possible and I don't
want to sound dumb so I'm going to
follow suit
um Tower any chance I could get the
actual ground frequency
anyway so we switched to ground then my
radio call would sound something like
this ground Cherokee 7348 Juliet clear
of three six at kilo request taxi 36 for
closed traffic
57348 Juliet taxi to 360 via alcohol
short three six three six via Alpha
holds short three six Cherokee seven
three four eight Juliet okay so taxi to
36 via Alpha holds short of three six is
my clearance according to 91 123 we are
required to follow this clearance now
but what if I change my mind because I
all of a sudden need to take a massive
you know and this FBO over here has a
great bathroom well there are basically
three ways to get out of a clearance and
the first way is to get an amended
clearance all you have to do is ask for
it now they won't always give it to you
but if they don't there's usually a
really good reason for it and if you
don't get an amended clearance you need
to follow the original clearance to the
letter let's ask ground for an amended
clearance ground Cherokee 734a Juliet
we've had a slight change of plans I
need a taxi to the South general
aviation parking and shut for a bit
taxi to the South Funeral Aviation ramp
via Alpha Taxi via Alpha 4A Juliet the
foreign
I'd rather not share the details but I'm
having a slight physiological episode 4A
Juliet
Roger 42 red
another way we can legally deviate from
an ATC clearance is during an emergency
let's say my brakes go out on me as I'm
taxing to the runway I probably don't
want a taxi onto the runway even if I am
having an emergency someone could
potentially land right on top of me I
may just want to kill the engine and
Coast to a stop I wasn't cleared to stop
on the taxiway but I'd say that might be
a pretty decent option don't you now it
would be nice to let ground know what
you're doing and get that amended
clearance but sometimes you just don't
have the time to get the radio call out
there another way you can legally
deviate from an ATC clearance is to
avoid hitting other aircraft let's say
I've been clear for takeoff on Runway 36
here and right before I turn to take the
runway I look up and I see someone about
to land right on top of me I look
straight ahead and I see that I can push
the power up and taxi onto four left
right before he hits me and no one's on
Final for that Runway should I do it of
course I should it's better to be judged
by 12 than carried by six but if you
didn't do anything wrong there's a
chance that you might not even need to
do paperwork for that deviation just let
ATC know as soon as possible if you do
something like this
Juliet just tax it on the floor left to
avoid that Landing aircraft copy that
foreign
four left Clifford takeoff 4A Juliet as
you can see that aircraft that landed on
the wrong Runway deviated from atc's
clearance not only did he break the law
but he almost caused the Collision
that's why it's so important to follow
these clearances if you need something
different than what you were given you
need to remember that these are the only
three good reasons to deviate from a
clearance that they give you
now as I mentioned a second ago in
addition to clearances we could also
just receive instructions from ATC these
might not necessarily be a clearance but
you still need to follow those
instructions as you can see here in 91
123 no person may operate contrary to an
ATC instruction in an area in which air
traffic control is exercised a good
example of this is when you're trying to
enter class Charlie airspace and you
make this radio call The Rock approach
Cherokee 7348 Juliet 15 nautical miles
to the Northwest at 3500 inbound with
Echo Cherokee 734a Julia remained clear
of the class Charlie airspace Roger I'll
stay clear that Charlie 734a Juliet now
this isn't a clearance but it is an
instruction and we cannot operate
contrary to that instruction no we don't
have to have a clearance to enter class
Charlie but this is one way they could
keep you out of the airspace if they
wanted but what happens if you lose
radio comms with ATC how do you get
instructions or an ATC clearance in that
situation if you're operating under via
for the best starting place for this
information is in the aim in section 4.
in paragraph 6-4-1 and if you're
operating under IFR you should read that
and then check out far 91185 but
basically the first step is to squawk
7600 on your transponder observe the
flow of traffic into the Airfield and
enter the pattern in an appropriate spot
then follow the light gun signals from
the tower
but the question is can I enter class
Charlie airspace without two-way radio
comms if my radio isn't working that's a
tricky question because this note in the
aim basically says land as soon as
practicable but then it says Pilots
retain the prerogative of exercising
their best judgment and are not required
to land at an unauthorized airport at an
airport unsuitable for the type of
aircraft flown or to land only minutes
short of their intended destination but
if you read the requirements for
entering class Charlie airspace in Far
91130 each person must establish two-way
radio communications with the ATC
facility providing air traffic Services
prior to entering that airspace and
thereafter maintain those Communications
while within that airspace now it goes
on later to say that you can call their
office and ask for a deviation but it
can be pretty difficult to do that from
an aircraft so basically if you haven't
established two-way radio comps before
you lose your radio you need to just
pick a small airport outside the
airspace to land at now if a greater
emergency exists you could always squawk
7700 to let them know you're an
emergency and at that point you can land
wherever you think is the safest place
to land but if you lose radios before
you enter class Charlie and because of
that you can't establish two-way radio
communications with ATC you just need to
land at the closest non-towered airport
and figure out things from there
with that in mind it is possible to land
at one of these locations call the
approach facility up on the phone and
ask if you can get permission to enter
the airspace without comms if they allow
it they'll give you some kind of
clearance and probably some instructions
on how they want you to enter the
airspace then they'll tell you to watch
for light gun signals from the tower
in addition to that you may also get a
squat code or they may just have you
squawk 7600 it all depends on the
approach facility okay let's say you had
two-way radio Cons with ATC and you lost
it right after entering the airspace
you've tried to reach them several times
and they're not answering so you squawk
7 600 to let them know you've lost comms
and now you're inbound for the runway
now you should be looking for light gun
signals coming from the tower
alternating green and red lights always
mean to exercise Extreme Caution most of
the time this will be one of the first
signals you see when you're headed
towards the pattern
now you should be trying to figure out
the best way to enter but if you ever
see flashing red that means the airport
is unsafe and you really need to find
somewhere else to land
if for some reason you see a steady red
light that just means that you should
give way and continue circling just find
a spot and make some gentle turns
outside the pattern and wait until you
get another signal from the tower
flashing green lights lets you know to
return for landing but you're not clear
to land yet when you get this one that
would be a good opportunity to enter the
pattern and to get ready to land you can
let them know you got the signal by
rocking your wings during the day or
flashing your Landing lights at night
then when you get the steady green light
from the tower you're cleared to Land
once you land and you're safely on the
ground the tower should give you the
flashing red light this is just telling
you to taxi clear the runway once you
clear the runway a flashing green light
lets you know that you're clear to taxi
and if you see a steady red stop the
aircraft and wait for the flashing green
light from now on you're playing the
adult version of red light green light
now on the ground there could be a time
when you need to take off from a
controlled airport without a working
radio maybe to get it fixed or something
once again you need to call the
appropriate facility and get permission
with them before you get in the plane so
we should call the tower in this case
since we're taking off from a towered
Airfield in this situation there may be
a few additional light gun signals you
need to know to get things going start
up your engine as you normally would
then point the nose of your aircraft
towards a tower and wait for the
flashing green light and that just lets
you know that you're clear to taxi once
again just watch the tower and stop if
you get the red light at some point you
could also get a flat flashing white
light while you're taxing if you get
this one that just means to return to
the starting point on the Airfield
wherever that was maybe the tower
decided that you needed to sign some
kind of paperwork before they let you
depart the field without a radio and
they wanted you to taxi back there could
be a million reasons for them having you
taxi back to your starting point but if
you don't get the flashing white light
just continue to taxi and hold short of
the runway until you get the steady
green light from the tower and this just
lets you know that you're cleared for
takeoff here's a look at all the light
gun signals you should be aware of
you'll find this chart in paragraph
4-3-13 of the aim this is a good one to
read over and it would also be a good
idea to print this guy out and put it
somewhere readily available in case you
need it okay the next thing I want to
talk about is somewhat of a complicated
topic but there are some aircraft
systems out there that can tell you to
deviate from an ATC clearance and on
some of these systems it's totally legal
to do so as you may remember in some
types of airspace we need to have a
transponder and adsb out not only do
these pieces of equipment tell a t see
where we are but they also show your
position to other aircraft so they can
keep from hitting you
if you have an iPad with foreflight as
long as it's connected to the internet
or an adsb Puck this can give you some
great situational Awareness on the
traffic around you but this does not
take the place of spotting the other
aircraft with your actual eyeballs and
you should never advise ATC that you
have the traffic in sight if you see
them on your iPad but not with your
actual eyes with that in mind there are
a few Advanced systems out there that
can provide a pilot with more detail on
the traffic in the area but there is
only one system out there that can
provide you with information that can
allow you to deviate from an ATC
clearance or instruction this system is
called traffic alert and collision
avoidance system or tcas now there are
actually two types of tcasts there's
tcas1 and tcas2 both systems interrogate
the transponders from other aircraft and
take their adsb information if it's
available to determine whether or not
that aircraft is going to be a collision
Hazard both versions display other
traffic in the area but in addition to
that when another aircraft gets too
close you'll also get something thing
called a traffic advisory that shows up
on the screen as a yellow circle and
gives this audible alert traffic
now if you if you remember from earlier
91123 actually says we can deviate from
an ATC clearance if it's in response to
a traffic alert and collision avoidance
system resolution advisory now I know
the wording is kind of confusing here
but what this is actually saying is you
can deviate with a tcas resolution
advisory not a traffic alert the aim
actually clarifies this just a little
bit better it says when a TA occurs
attempt to establish visual contact with
the traffic but do not deviate from an
assigned clearance based only on ta
information okay so how should we treat
one of these traffic advisories or
traffic alerts here's kind of what I do
as soon as you see the traffic advisory
you should immediately start looking for
that traffic if you really do think that
traffic is going to be an issue ATC is
most likely going to help you by giving
you a vector but I would probably not
deviate from an ATC clearance unless
you're a hundred percent sure that this
guy's gonna hit you you also need to be
100 sure on what you need to do to avoid
the collision and a traffic alert really
doesn't give you that information with
that in mind take cast 2 can issue
something called a resolution advisory
which actually does tell you what to do
if the system thinks that you're going
to hit that other aircraft usually
you'll get the traffic alert first then
you'll get a resolution advisory that'll
help you avoid the Collision traffic
traffic climb climb increase climb
increase climb if you get this advisory
you can and should follow these
instructions to the letter because your
life probably depends on it in either
case as soon as you know the traffic is
no longer a factor you should always
notify ATC as soon as possible
especially if you deviated from a
clearance for the rock approach Cherokee
7348 Juliet we just climbed for a
resolution advisory looks like the
traffic is no Factor now Rancher 4A
Julia sorry about that his transpanda
just popped up seconds before you
maneuvered he must have been having
issues with his transponder now I know
most Cherokees aren't going to have TCS
but systems like this are getting more
and more common and it's very likely you
could fly an aircraft that has it with
your PPL and like I said we should
always follow the clearances and
instructions from ATC but if we want to
be good Pilots we also need to use a
little bit of common sense if a
dangerous situation is developing don't
just follow a TC blind finally I've
flown in mountainous terrain before and
had ATC try to Vector me right into the
side of a mountain they actually tried
to do it multiple times obviously I'm
not going to kill myself just because
I'm trying to follow their instructions
but as soon as I got the heading I knew
it wasn't going to work so I spoke up
Julia just advise me when you're on the
three two zero heading Juliet now if you
ever do deviate from an ATC clearance
even if it is an emergency there's
always the chance that the controller
could have you give them a call
foreignty go ahead and give me a call at
this number do you have a good way to
write this down I can't write anything
down right now I'm too busy flying I'm
just kidding don't do that take the
number and call them once you're on the
ground sometimes they may just need a
little bit more information on why you
did what you did maybe the controller
made a mistake and they don't want it to
happen again it might not always be your
fault there's also a chance that they
could request a written report from you
and if that happens you have 48 hours to
submit that to their office even if you
had an emergency and you didn't break
any rules you could still get asked for
a written report and the reason for this
is because you get priority over all
other aircraft when you declare an
emergency and they need to have that
information for their records and once
again if you're asked for a written
report you have 48 hours to submit that
report and he'll tell you exactly where
to send it once it's done I hope you
learned something from today's video in
my next video we're going to be talking
about some of the regulations when it
comes to Safety in the airplane when I'm
done with that video I'll put it right
year in the meantime check this video
out you're gonna like it I'll see you
over there see it oh you're not gonna
believe this I just bought it free pilot
training I'm going to keep on watching